what i want to do in this video is
re-simplify this expression 3 times the
principal root of 500 times x to the
third and take it into consideration
some of the comments that we got out on
youtube that actually uh give some
interest interesting perspective on how
you can simplify this so just as a quick
review of what we did in the last video
we said that this is the same thing as 3
times the principal root of 500 and i'm
going to do it a little bit different
than i did in the last video just just
to make it interesting this is 3 times
the principal root of 500 times the
principal root of x to the third
and 500 we can rewrite it because 500 is
not a perfect square we can rewrite 500
as
100 times 5 or even better we can
rewrite that as ten squared times five
ten squared is the same thing as a
hundred so we can rewrite this first
part over here as three times the
principal root of ten squared times five
times
times the principal root of x squared
times x that's the same thing as x to
the third now the one thing i'm going to
do here actually i won't talk about it
just yet of how we're going to do it
differently than we did in the last
video this radical right here can be
rewritten as so this is going to be 3
times the square root or the principal
root i should say of 10 squared
times the square root of 5. if we take
the square root of the product of two
things it's the same thing as taking the
square root of each of them and then
taking the product
and so and this over here is going to be
times the square root of or the
principal root of x squared
times the principle root of x
and
the principal root of 10 squared is 10.
and then what i said in the last video
is that the principal root of x squared
is going to be the absolute value of x
just in case just in case x itself is a
negative number and so then if you
simplify all of this you get 3 times 10
which is 30 times and i'm just going to
switch the order here times the absolute
value of x and then you have the square
root of 5 or the principal root of 5
times the principal root of x and this
is just going to be equal to the
principal root of 5x taking the square
root of something and multiplying that
times the square root of something else
is the same thing as just taking the
square root of 5x so all of this
simplified down to 30 times the absolute
value of x times the principal root of
5x and this is what we got in the last
video and the interesting thing here is
if we assume we're only dealing with
real numbers the domain of x right over
here the x's that will make this
expression defined in the real numbers
then x has to be
x has to be greater than or equal to
zero so let me
so maybe i could write it this way the
domain here
the domain here is that x
is x any
any real number
real number
greater than or equal to zero and the
reason why i say that is if you put a
negative number in here if you put a
negative number in here and you cube it
you're going to get another negative
number and then it doesn't make it's at
least in the real numbers that you won't
get you won't get an actual you won't
get an actual value you'll get a square
root of a negative number here so if you
make this if you assume this right here
we're dealing with the real numbers
we're not dealing with any complex
numbers when you when you open up the
complex numbers then you can have a then
you can expand the domain more broadly
but if you're dealing with real numbers
you can say that x is going to be
greater than or equal to 0 and then the
absolute value of x is just going to be
x because it's not going to be a
negative number and so if we're assuming
that the domain of x is
or if this value this expression is
going to be valuable or
it's going to have a positive number
then this can be written as 30x times
the square root of 5x if you if you if
you had the situation where we were
dealing with complex numbers then you
would so numbers that were and if you
don't know what a complex number is or
an imaginary number don't worry too much
about it but if you were dealing with
those then you would have to keep the
absolute value of x there because then
this would be defined this would be
defined for numbers that are less than
zero